تضائلت فرص العوده للديار فاستعراض
اللاجئون عن الخيام بالمساكن الخشبيه
يحتضن هذا المخيم الواقع غربي اثيوبيا
قرابه خمسين الفا من لاجئ جنوب السودان
بعضهم ولد وترعرع هنا هو احدى الصور
الماساويه لافرازات الحرب في القاره
وللحد من تبعات الحروب اطلق الاتحاد
الافريقي مبادره لاسكات البنادق وهي
مقاربه قاريه شامله لمنع النزاعات
وادارتها وتعزيز اليات المصالحه لجعل
افريقيا خاليه من اي حروب بحلول عام 2030
لتحقيق هذه المبادره الاتحاد الافريقي كون
منظومه للحكم الرشيد هذه المنظومه تسعى
الى تشجيع القاره او دول القاره الافريقيه
لتعزيز اسس الحكم الرشيد على مستوى على
المستوى المحلي والمستوى القومي والمستوى
القاري
تعد اتفاقيه السلام الاثيوبيه احدث
انجازات المبادره اذ وضعت وبجهود افريقيه
خالصه حدا للصراع دام عامين في بلد محوري
بالقاره كاثيوبيا ورغم السلام المحرز هنا
ظلت ماكينه الحروب مستعره في اماكن اخرى
مضطر الاتحاد الافريقي الى تمديد عامل
المبادره التي كان مقررا وقف العمل بها
عام 2020 عشر سنوات اخرى
اذا نظرنا الى خطه التنفيذ فانها تواجه
مشكلات في القضايا السياسيه والامنيه
والمبادره تتطلب استجابه كامله ومتعدده
الاطراف وتحتاج لدعم اوسع من الدول
الاعضاء والشركاء لكن التحدي الاكبر في
رايي يتعلق بمساله الحوكمه والحكم الرشيد
وانشاء حكومات قادره على تلبيه احتياجات
السكان
افريقيا باكثر من 14 نزاعا نشطا يتصدرها
الصراع مع جماعات التطرف العنيف كما يصفها
الاتحاد الافريقي والتي تشمل دولا
كالصومالي ومالي وموزمبيق ونيجيريا
وبوركينا فاسو والنيجر وتشهد القاره
الافريقيه صراعات ضد الحركات المتمرده او
الانفصاليه فيما تعد الصراعات العرقيه
احدى المعضلات الامنيه في كل من اثيوبيا
والسودان وجنوب السودان سبع سنوات تفصلنا
عن موعد الاتحاد الافريقي لانهاء الحروب
في القاره سقف زمني قد لا يكون واقعيا
مقارنه بحجم التعقيدات لكن المتفائلين
يشيرون الى ان ما تحقق من سلام رغم
التحديات يعد فرصه ينبغي البناء عليها
لتحقيق الهدف المنشود
حسن رزاق الجزيره اديس ابابا